well joining me now is chief executive
of the royal meteorological society liz
bentley and let's just remind us what
does an amber warning mean
yeah so it's basically to uh to warn us
of the heat that's coming and there's a
heat health warning as well that's also
been issued and it's about taking action
now over the next few days as
temperatures start to rise
and peak probably around friday i think
into the mid 30s but over the course of
the next few days temperatures reaching
those heatwave categories so getting
into the high 20s and the low 30s and
then peaking around the mid 30s on
friday
and not just daytime temperatures
getting to get into those high levels
but also nighttime temperatures will be
staying up and we could see one or two
tropical nights over the course of the
next few days and that's where the
temperature doesn't drop below 20
degrees celsius so we need to take
action to to be able to look after
vulnerable people the elderly who
struggle a little bit more when we get
these heat events but also for for you
know generally healthy human beings just
to take extra precautions because of the
heat so taking on extra water keeping
hydrated and keeping out of the heat as
best you can
now we had high temperatures in july and
we understand that these temperatures
aren't going to be as high as this does
this therefore mean it's not as serious
yeah so we we saw over 40 degrees at the
end of july and i don't suspect during
this heatwave event that we'll see
temperatures reaching 40 degrees
this week
but it's a more prolonged period so if
you remember at the end of july probably
was about a 48-hour period where we had
the intense heat this is lasting for for
a longer period of about five or six
days uh until the heat
warning is in place now until
sunday this week
and so it's that prolonged period that
actually can be
more damaging really to our health
because it puts extra strain on our body
day and night day and night
consecutively day after day and that's
really where the health problems start
to come because our bodies don't have
time to rest and recuperate you know the
high temperatures mean it's working very
hard to keep us cool both day and night
and when we put that extra strain on it
on our bodies day after day that's where
we're going to start to see some
problems people you know struggling with
heat exhaustion
we often see an increase in mortality
rate when we get temperatures this high
as well
and and in terms of of what's happening
after this do we expect uh i mean i know
that there's a limit to how far ahead
you're able to predict but are we
expecting more spells of hot summer hot
weather over the summer or
or is the feeling that this could be the
end of it
so just looking at the forecast ahead i
think you know that the high
temperatures the really extreme heat
that lead to these heat wave warnings
there's nothing in the forecast yet as
we go through august it's a bit too
early to to really kind of see the
detail
but i would say because of climate
change we are you know seeing more
heatwave events they're becoming more
frequent when they happen they tend to
be more prolonged and we get these
intense heat events the kind of
record-breaking events that we saw at
the end of july so these are happening
more often so whether we see more this
year or in future years as i say the
likelihood is they're just going to
increase in in frequency and intensity
as we go forward in time
the fact that we are seeing these
extreme periods of different weather be
it very hot weather wet weather does it
tell us anything about what what's going
to come ahead in the autumn and in the
winter did the fact that it has been so
hot this summer doesn't mean it will be
a milder winter or or or could it be the
opposite
yeah so we don't tend to have these
linkages to what the weather's doing in
one season as to how it's going to
change as we move into the next season
we do have seasonal forecasts we have
longer range forecasts that give us that
extra detail of trends of whether things
are going to be above or below average
whether that's temperature or rainfall
and then we obviously have our climate
projections that look decades or you
know a century ahead and it's the
climate projections that are really
giving us that steer to the fact that
you know if if we look forward in time
we're going to see warmer wetter winters
more likely in future hotter drier
summers as we go forward in time and
we've already seen that starting to play
out in our changing climate already but
it's going to you know
lead to a kind of longer longer trend as
we go forward as well
uh and and in terms of that longer trend
that is the pattern is it that we're
just going to have to get used to
absolutely so things that we see as
extreme now the temperature of 40
degrees at the end of july and 36 at the
end of the this week if you think we've
only recorded 36 degrees in this country
13 times and 10 of those happened since
the turn of the century since 2000
they're becoming more frequent events
but we still see them as extreme if we
go forward a few decades 36 degrees or
even 40 degrees that we saw at the end
of july are going to become much more
normal temperatures that we see in the
summer not seen as extreme events as
we'd still class them today
okay
good a good chance to remind everybody
to keep
out of the sun if you possibly can and
as you say keep hydrated and try and
avoid getting too much of it liz bentley
from the royal meteorological society
thank you very much thank you